good morning Hank it's Sunday what is
today you note the day it is Sunday
December 20th French the llama that
means I'm scheduled to have a baby in
exactly one month well actually as I
said last time I'm not gonna have it
Sarah is gonna have it but you know I'm
gonna be there annoying her being like
does it hurt
really is it bad it's like a wedgie what
what is it like a worse version of a
wedgie
okay Hank today's video comes you in two
parts part one awesome project is
awesome Hank the 2009 project for
awesome has been the awesomest project
for awesome ever in fact hank according
to my calculations this year's project
for awesome put three years worth of
Awesome into 48 hours but more on that
in a second for the majority of the
project for awesome the hashtag p4a was
trending above the movie avatar avatar
which costs 250 million dollars to make
was beaten by the project for awesome
which costs $0 there were more than two
thousand project for awesome videos this
year and we commented on them more than
a million times now actually this is not
a joke I commented so much during that
48 hours that I hurt my left shoulder
and take the thousands of people who are
falling along the show and livestream
and commenting and rating and favoriting
like crazy ended up spending a combined
three years rating and favoriting and
commenting during the 48 hours of the
project for awesome and oh I cannot just
stick you late okay only one arm
gesticulation i want to take everyone
who hosted the livestream show from
morning johnson to natalie trans to
several of the five awesome girls to liz
and karen kavett and alan fall of autumn
distro i want to thank everybody who
rated and commented and favorited videos
to get those videos about charity to a
new audience I also want to thank John
Henson Meyer who designed the 2009
project for awesome logo and most of all
I want to thank everybody who made a
video from people with hundreds of
thousands of subscribers like Lisa Nova
and Shay Carl and Kasim g2 people with
fewer than 100 subscribers like Tom
Tughlaq and Maddy bouche this year we
got thousands of comments and ratings on
more project for awesome videos than
ever before and next year we're gonna do
even better now that we've brought
attention to organizations that decrease
worldsuck I hope all of you will join me
in donating to some of our favorites I'm
still figuring out which charities my
thousand dollars is going to but
remember if you want to get my baby of
present you can do so at first giving
org slash John's baby hates malaria
and there are still several project for
awesome items being auctioned off at
eBay including a nerdfighter who is
auctioning off his bobblehead of me to
benefit my charity water you can find
all that and more links about how to
continue the project for awesome so
awesome in the doobly-doo by the way do
you remember like two minutes ago when I
said French the llama I should probably
explain that Hank as you know I'm not
much of an expert at your internet memes
or Mimi's muumuus
I have trouble following along with the
internet muumuus and so in comments I
kept seeing people say world suck FTL
and I was like what does FTL mean well
it turns out it means for the lose but a
nerdfighter tricked me into thinking it
means French the llama which is what it
should mean and I think it should be an
exclamation of amazement like French the
llama the square root of negative one is
a letter Hank thank you for inventing
the idea of the project for awesome and
for all the work you did to make it
happen and I will see you on two Oh
part two it's December 20th which means
it's almost the end of the year and at
the end of ah why do I keep forgetting
how much it hurts to move at the end of
each year the vlogbrothers channel
traditionally reinvents itself which
we're gonna do this year as well
nerdfighteria but we need help from you
what do you want to see more of and just
as important what do you not want to see
anymore should we buy an island should
we be more project-based more news more
funny more interaction should I wear
pants when I vlog let us know in
comments and please know that we take
your comments seriously and we always
read them all
well let me except during the project
for awesome nerdfighters I love you Hank
you're also pretty cool I'll see you on
Tuesday